Whitehouse trade advisor Peter Navarro
joins me now to discuss that of more
good evening Peter I would like to start
with a comment made by former President
Barack Obama at a commencement speech
just a few hours ago where he knocks
quote the folks in charge basically
saying that the government officials in
charge of responding to coronavirus show
totally that they were incompetent and
that they obviously don't know what
they're doing a lot of them aren't even
pretending to be in charge what say you
in response to that yeah it was that a
speech today or was that like a
political ad I do want to congratulate
the former president on his new job as
press secretary for the candidate locked
in the basement
good job will be be happy to see out
there in the trail look eight years of
Obama and Biden was a cumbia of
incompetence this was the guy on his
watch that we saw over 50,000 factories
disappear to China didn't mention that
in his speech right and to the to the
American workers it was always you know
let them eat arugula this was like you
would have to wave a magic wand to get
back manufacturing vici with Donald J
Trump got half a million manufacturing
jobs back
so I little little surprised at the
former president coming out like that
but again as as Biden's press
Secretary's going to do that here's the
challenge I got two challenges the dog
that didn't bark in that in that speech
was absolutely no mention of the role of
China in this pandemic so I'm going to
start counting the days that we we don't
hear from Joe Biden and Barack Obama on
the fact that China caused this pandemic
and and basically unleashed a trillions
of dollars of damage on this world and
and the loss of to date over 80,000
American lives so I'd like to see that
and here's another challenge do you
think that the obama-biden
administration ever could have stood up
a ventilator Factory in 17 days do you
think the Obama
biding administration could have built
two factories making n95 masks in five
weeks instead of the usual nine months I
don't think so and if you move forward
to what this president is going to do
this week I did see a turnaround history
will mark this week was the turnaround
we got the economy back open in 48 of
the 50 states that's number one
President Donald J Trump announced a
strategic stockpile in His image smarter
stronger more resilient we have a
vaccine Manhattan Project that is going
to basically get us to a vaccine in in
what I call Trump time which is as soon
as possible with the gold in December
and we can talk about how we might get
to that and these are the kinds of
things along with building the best
economy in the last 50 years that Barack
Obama and Joe Biden ever could have done
and Joe Biden never will do in his
lifetime